أهلاً بكم مجدداً في الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي، أنا مقدمتكم Olivia Lanes في المرة السابقة استعرضنا مثالاً على
نهج الحوسبة الكمومية لمشكلة تحسين تُعرف بـ Max Cut باستخدام صيغة QUBO، وقد تعمقنا
كثيراً لكن ذلك كان مجرد مثال واحد لنهج واحد. اليوم سنناقش تطبيقات المدى القريب
بشكل أوسع ونطور حدسنا لأنواع مختلفة من المشاكل التي نتوقع أن نجد لها حلولاً كمومية مفيدة
ونستعرض بعض الأمثلة الحديثة لأعمال مهمة أُنجزت في مجتمعنا على مستوى
الفائدة العملية. سابقاً ناقشنا بإيجاز أن ليس كل المشاكل تحتاج إلى قوة حسابية إضافية
وتحديداً الحوسبة الكمومية لكي تُحل بكفاءة. هذه هي المشاكل التي أنتم بالفعل على دراية كبيرة
بها كالحساب وتصفح وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وربما لعب Tetris أو Doom أو ألعاب فيديو أخرى. نعتبر هذه بشكل عام
مشاكل سهلة. من ناحية أخرى هناك مشاكل صعبة جداً مثل إيجاد العوامل الأولية لأعداد صحيحة
ضخمة وهذا هو أساس تشفير RSA وما صُمم خوارزمية Shor لحله فعلياً. مثال
آخر هو إيجاد حل في مجموعة بيانات غير مرتبة، ويمكن نظرياً حل هذا بالخوارزمية الكمومية المعروفة
بخوارزمية Grover. لكن معظم الخبراء يتفقون على أن هذه الأنواع من الخوارزميات ستتطلب
تطبيق تصحيح الأخطاء ونحن لم نصل إلى هناك بعد من الناحية التقنية. لذا بينما نمضي قدماً في هذا
الدرس وفي رحلتكم التعليمية الكمومية، تذكروا أننا نبحث عن هذه النقطة المثالية في مكان ما هنا في المنتصف
إنها مشكلة صعبة الحل لكن هذا أيضاً ما يجعلها ممتعة جداً. شيء واحد لم نناقشه
كثيراً بعد هو نظرية التعقيد الحسابي. أحد الأسباب هو أنها قد تكون مخيفة بعض الشيء ونعم
معقدة. نظرية التعقيد الحسابي هي مجال في علوم الحاسوب يهدف إلى تصنيف المشاكل الحسابية
حسب صعوبتها. هناك عدد كبير من فئات التعقيد المختلفة في الحوسبة الكلاسيكية لكن الأكثر
أساسية هي مشاكل P. هذه مشاكل يمكن حلها في زمن متعدد الحدود عند التوسع مع
زيادة حجم المشكلة مما يعني أنها سهلة الحل. النوع الأصعب التالي هو مشاكل NP التي
تعني متعدد الحدود غير القطعي. هذه مشاكل يمكن التحقق من إجاباتها في زمن متعدد الحدود لكن ليس
بالضرورة حلها. التالي هو NP-complete والآن ندخل في المشاكل الصعبة حقاً بدون
حل متعدد الحدود معروف. هنا تعيش مشاكل شهيرة مثل مشكلة البائع المتجول وحتى لعبة
Sudoku. الآن عندما ظهرت الحوسبة الكمومية على الأقل نظرياً بذل الناس جهداً كبيراً لمحاولة
معرفة أي فئة من المشاكل ستتمكن هذه الأنواع الجديدة من الحواسيب من حلها بكفاءة. فئة جديدة من
المشاكل اُبتكرت تُسمى مشاكل الخطأ المحدود الكمومية متعددة الحدود أو BQP اختصاراً. تعريفها الدقيق
طويل بعض الشيء لكنها فئة مشاكل القرار القابلة للحل بواسطة حاسوب كمومي في زمن متعدد الحدود مع احتمال
خطأ صغير. هناك احتمال خطأ لأن القياس الكمومي عشوائي بطبيعته لكن احتمال
الخطأ يمكن أن يكون صغيراً بشكل تعسفي. الآن كل هذه الفئات تعيش في فئة أكبر نسميها PSPACE وهنا
نعتقد أن BQP تقع بالنسبة لجميع أنواع المشاكل الأخرى لكن من الصعب جداً إثبات هذا بشكل قاطع
رياضياً. ستلاحظون أن مشاكل BQP الكمومية لا تتداخل بالضرورة مع مشاكل NP-complete
لكن ربما رأيتم بعض مقاربات الحوسبة الكمومية التي تهدف لحل مشاكل NP-complete. لماذا
يكون هذا؟ أحد المفاهيم الخاطئة الشائعة هو أنه لا جدوى من استكشاف حلول
لمشاكل مثل البائع المتجول ومشاكل NP-complete الأخرى للحاسوب الكمومي أو أي مشكلة لم يُثبت
رياضياً وجود تسريع كمومي لها. لكن هذا ليس بالضرورة صحيحاً
فإيجاد إثبات رياضي بأن خوارزمية كمومية أسرع من نظيرتها الكلاسيكية أمر نادر. Shor و
Grover هما اثنان فقط من حفنة أمثلة تم فيها ذلك حتى الآن. لكن لا بأس ففي الواقع علماء
الحاسوب لم يتمكنوا حتى الآن من إثبات أن فئتي P و NP مختلفتان رغم أن كل الحدس
يقول لنا أنهما كذلك. كذلك فإن مقارنة خوارزميتين وكيف تتوسعان غالباً ما تنظر في أسوأ السيناريوهات
لكل منهما. من الممكن تماماً أنه عملياً لا نواجه أسوأ السيناريوهات في الحياة الواقعية لذا
لا نيأس. بل نقدم فكرة الحلول الاستدلالية. إذا كنتم
تجريبيين فأنتم تعرفون وتحبون هذه الأنواع من الحلول بالفعل. الحل الاستدلالي هو أي نهج لحل
مشكلة يكون عملياً لكن ليس بالضرورة مثالياً. وهذا رائع لأن الحلول لا يجب أن تكون
مثالية لتكون مفيدة جداً. مثلاً فكروا في تطبيق مالي، لم نجد بعد
تسريعاً أسياً لمعظم الخوارزميات المالية التي يمكن استخدام الكم فيها بعد، لكن هذا لا يهم بالضرورة. لا نحتاج حلاً مثالياً
في المالية على الأقل لأن حلاً أكثر كفاءة بنسبة 1% فقط قد يعادل مليارات الدولارات
من الأرباح. إذاً كيف نعرف أي حالات الاستخدام والمشاكل قد تكون مناسبة للحوسبة الكمومية الآن، وأعني بذلك
أن هناك سبباً مهماً للاعتقاد بأن الفائدة الكمومية أو حتى التفوق يمكن إيجاده إما الآن أو
في المستقبل القريب نوعاً ما. ربما من الأسهل أولاً تسمية الأشياء التي يجب ألا تتضمنها المشكلة بالتأكيد
لا يمكن أن تتطلب عدداً ضخماً من الـ qubit. ليس لدينا معالجات بعد تمتلك آلافاً إلى ملايين الـ qubit المتاحة وهذا أحد الأسباب الرئيسية
لكون خوارزمية Shor وأمثالها بعيدة جداً. كذلك لا يمكن أن تكون الـ circuit عميقة بشكل لا يصدق. من الصعب جداً علي
أن أخبركم بالضبط أي عمق circuit لن ينجح لأنه يعتمد على عوامل كثيرة جداً لكن بشكل عام إذا كانت
تجربتكم تتطلب عمقاً لم تروه قد تحقق في الأدبيات العلمية بعد فقد تواجهون وقتاً صعباً
وأخيراً أي نوع من الخوارزميات نعلم أنها ستتطلب تصحيح الأخطاء لا يمكن تنفيذه بعد. ما يجب أن نبحث عنه هو تجارب تستخدم
معظم الـ qubit المتاحة على أي وحدة معالجة كمومية. كما أننا نؤكد على
أهمية تخفيف وقمع الأخطاء، وأخيراً يجب أن يكون هناك امتداد واضح لتطبيقات مستقبلية
مهمة للمجتمع ويمكن أن نرى أنها تؤدي في النهاية إلى التفوق
الكمومي. الآن لنتحدث عن بعض أمثلة حالات الاستخدام التي تندرج تحت ثلاث فئات رئيسية حددناها
على أنها الأكثر احتمالاً لرؤية نتائج إيجابية في المدى القريب إلى
المتوسط. المجال الأول هو محاكاة الطبيعة. تحدثنا عن هذا سابقاً وهناك
فرص كثيرة جداً للحواسيب الكمومية لتحسين البحث الجاري على المستوى الجزيئي والذري
والسبب في ذلك هو أن الطرق الكلاسيكية الحالية محدودة بأوصاف رياضية غير فعالة جوهرياً
للبنى الذرية. تخزين ومعالجة حالة كمومية يتطلب كمية أسية من الموارد
على حاسوب كلاسيكي لكن يمكن القيام بذلك بكفاءة على حاسوب كمومي وهذا ما يجعل محاكاة المواد
والنمذجة الكيميائية من أكثر مجالات التطبيق الواعدة. وبشكل أكثر تحديداً قد يؤدي هذا إلى
تطورات في احتجاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون والبطاريات البديلة أو اختراع أدوية جديدة. بعض
الخوارزميات ذات الصلة بشكل خاص في هذا المجال هي محلل القيم الذاتية الكمومي التباينيي VQE الذي يُستخدم
لتقدير خصائص معينة لمادة ما مثل حالات التوازن أو الطاقة الدنيا. مثال آخر هو
محاكاة الديناميكا الزمنية TDS. تُستخدم تلك الخوارزمية لتقدير دوال الاستجابة أو الخصائص الطيفية
للمواد. وأردت أيضاً أن أذكر وافداً جديداً وهو التقطير الكمومي القائم على العينات الذي نعتقد أننا
سنسمع عنه أكثر بكثير في المستقبل القريب. مجال التطبيق التالي هو التحسين. التحسين منتشر
بشكل كبير في الحوسبة كما يمكنكم أن تتخيلوا لذا حالات الاستخدام متعددة ومتنوعة
لكن بعض الأمثلة التي نسمع عنها كثيراً هي تحسين المحافظ الاستثمارية في المالية والتصميم الصناعي وكذلك
التوزيع وسلسلة التوريد. الخوارزمية الأكثر شيوعاً التي ستسمعون عنها في التحسين هي تلك التي
غطيناها بالفعل بشيء من العمق وهي خوارزمية التحسين التقريبي الكمومي أو
QAOA. وأخيراً مجال واحد شهد الكثير من الحماس في السنوات القليلة الماضية هو التعلم الآلي الكمومي. أعتقد
أنه من العدل القول أنه يبدو أن التعلم الآلي الكمومي لن يحدث بالسرعة التي ستحدث بها المحاكاة على الأرجح لكن مع ذلك هناك
بعض الخوارزميات المبهرة التي يعمل عليها الناس باستمرار والمرتبطة ببعض حالات الاستخدام
المهمة جداً. بعض حالات الاستخدام المحتملة هي معالجة اللغة الطبيعية وتحليل حركة الشبكات وحتى اكتشاف
الاحتيال في المعاملات المالية. الخوارزميات ذات الصلة في هذا المجال هي آلة المتجهات الداعمة الكمومية
والشبكات العصبية الكمومية والشبكات التوليدية التنافسية الكمومية. الآن لتوضيح تلك المجموعات الثلاث
التي وصفناها هي مجالات تطبيق واسعة. من الجدير بالذكر أيضاً أنه في المجتمع هناك
فائدة لمجموعات تعمل معاً وتركز على موضوع محدد. IBM أطلقت مبادرة منذ فترة ليست طويلة
تُسمى مجموعات العمل لمحاولة مساعدة المتعاونين على الالتقاء وخلق تآزر منتج في أربعة مجالات
محددة: الرعاية الصحية وعلوم الحياة والمواد والحوسبة عالية الأداء وفيزياء الطاقات العالية
والتحسين. هذه مجموعاتنا الحالية والجهات المشاركة في تلك الجهود. إذا أردتم سماع المزيد عن
ما تقوم به مجموعات العمل فقد أرفقنا أربعاً من أوراقهم البيضاء في الوصف أدناه. كما قلت
أعتقد أن أفضل شيء نفعله في هذه المرحلة من الدورة هو قضاء بعض الوقت في استكشاف أنواع المشاكل التي يعمل عليها الناس في طليعة
هذه التقنية وتطوير حدسنا لمعرفة أنواع الخوارزميات التي ستنجح وكيفية
تطبيقها. وقبل أن نبدأ أريد أن أوضح تماماً أن الهدف الرئيسي هنا ليس فهم كل
تفصيل في التجارب. هذا النوع من التحليل يمكن أن يكون مخيفاً حتى للخبراء إذا كانت الورقة خارج
مجال تخصصكم قليلاً. الهدف ببساطة هو المساعدة في تطوير حدس لأنواع المشاكل التي الحواسيب الكمومية
جيدة فيها وكيفية التعامل معها. وإذا كنتم مهتمين بالتفاصيل الدقيقة وهذا أشعل بعض
الأفكار لديكم فأنا أشجعكم بشدة على قراءة الأوراق الكاملة بأنفسكم. حالات الاستخدام والأوراق
المحددة التي سنلقي عليها نظرة معمقة هي هذه: أولاً سنستكشف ورقة تناقش
محاكاة ديناميكا الهادرونات. يندرج هذا ضمن فئة فيزياء الطاقات العالية. بعد ذلك سننظر في مشكلة تحسين
وتحديداً التحسين الكمومي المضاد للكظوم بحقل الانحياز. وأخيراً سننظر في مشكلة
محاكاة أخرى لكن هذه المرة تركز على الحمض النووي الريبوزي المرسال وهو جزيء حاسم
لتطوير الأدوية والعلاجات. سواء كنتم على دراية بهذه الأوراق أم لا فلا مشكلة سنستعرضها
جميعاً. الثلاث أوراق مهمة تتناول مشاكل بحجم كبير وتوضح كيف أن الحواسيب
الكمومية بدأت تُستخدم كأسلوب آخر للبحث العلمي. أولاً محاكاة ديناميكا
الهادرونات وسنتعمق في ورقة لمجموعة Martin Savage في جامعة Washington بعنوان المحاكاة الكمومية
لديناميكا الهادرونات في نموذج Schwinger باستخدام 112
qubit. إذا لم تكونوا فيزيائيي طاقات عالية فربما لا تزالون على دراية بمصطلح هادرون كما في
مصادم الهادرونات الكبير أو LHC وهو مسرع الجسيمات العملاق الذي يبلغ محيطه 27 كيلومتراً والذي أتاح
أخيراً رصد بوزون Higgs. الهادرون هو جسيم دون ذري مركب يتكون من جسيمات
أصغر تُسمى كواركات. بعض الأمثلة هي النيوترونات والبروتونات. لبعض السياق بُني مصادم الهادرونات الكبير
للسماح بدراسة الفيزياء الأساسية وما يحدث للجسيمات عندما تصطدم بطاقات فائقة العلو
في هذا الأنبوب الدائري. بفعل ذلك يأمل العلماء في معرفة المزيد عن كيفية نشأة الكون المبكر
وكما ذكرت سابقاً استُخدم أيضاً لإيجاد بوزون Higgs وهو جسيم مراوغ مسؤول عن كتلة
الجسيمات الأساسية. الآن من حيث المبدأ تفاعلات هذه الجسيمات يمكن
محاكاتها من البداية إلى النهاية بحاسوب كمومي قوي بما يكفي. لم نصل إلى هناك بعد لكن التقدم
يتحقق. نموذج Schwinger هو نموذج بسيط يُستخدم لمحاكاة بعض هذه الديناميكيات وقد برز كواحد من
أكثر النماذج المختارة شيوعاً. تفاصيل النموذج ليست فائقة الأهمية الآن لكن لمن يرغب
بالمعرفة هو نموذج يصف سلوك الإلكترونات والبوزيترونات المتفاعلة عبر الفوتونات في بُعد 1+1
أي أن هناك بُعداً مكانياً واحداً والزمن. النموذج لديه الكثير من التشابه مع الديناميكا اللونية
الكمومية التي تصف كيف تتفاعل الكواركات والهادرونات. وهذا صعب للغاية المحاكاة لذا
نموذج Schwinger يُستخدم غالباً كنموذج مبسط لدراسة بعض الظواهر المشتركة بين
الاثنين. الآن الطريقة التي سنتبعها مع هذا المثال وبقية الأمثلة التي اخترتها هي
بطرح سلسلة من الأسئلة على أنفسنا. السؤال الأول هو لماذا كان لدينا سبب للاعتقاد بأن محاكاة هذا
على حاسوب كمومي ستنجح أصلاً. في هذه الحالة الإلكترونات والبوزيترونات في نموذج Schwinger لديها تأثير حجب
يسبب تلاشي الارتباطات بين الفرميونات البعيدة أسياً مع المسافة وهذا يعني أن هناك
ليست هناك تفاعلات بعيدة المدى كثيرة من qubit على جانب واحد من الشريحة إلى آخر على الجانب الآخر
وهو ما نعلم أنه عرضة للأخطاء بشدة. لذا هذا جيد جداً للعتاد المتاح لدينا اليوم. التالي هل
هذا الموضوع مثير للاهتمام أصلاً؟ حسناً أتمنى أنني أقنعتكم بالفعل أن نعم فيزياء الطاقات العالية ذات أهمية
كبيرة. الناس كانوا مستعدين لإنفاق مليارات الدولارات لبناء مصادم الهادرونات الكبير وآلاف العلماء
والتقنيين حول العالم كرسوا حياتهم لهذا المجال. هكذا هو مهم. لكن
نموذج Schwinger مبسط وليس مصمماً لتغطية ثلاثة أبعاد مكانية. مع ذلك هو نموذج
مهم لأنه لا يزال يوفر شرائح قابلة للاختبار حالياً وتبسيطاً مفيداً لنظرية
كاملة. أخيراً كيف تم هذا العمل أو ما النهج الذي سيستخدمونه إذا أرادوا مواصلة العمل في
تجارب من نوع المحاكاة؟ VQE هو أحد أكثر الأساليب شيوعاً والخطوة الأولى هي دائماً تقريباً نفسها
تحضير الحالة الأرضية. في هذه الحالة هي حالة الفراغ وفي هذه التجربة استخدموا نسخة جديدة من VQE تُسمى SC
adapt VQE لتحضير كل من الحالة الأرضية وحزمة موجة الهادرون فوق الفراغ. الخطوة التالية هي
السماح للهادرونات بالتطور أو الانتشار عبر الزمن. وأخيراً نحتاج لتحديد
المرصودات التي نريد كشفها. إذا بدت لكم تلك الخطوات مألوفة نوعاً ما باستثناء جزء حزمة موجة
الهادرون فذلك لأن هذه الخطوات مشابهة جداً لما غطيناه في مثال QAOA في الحلقة السابقة
آملاً أنكم بدأتم ترون بعض الأنماط تتبلور هنا. المكونات المطلوبة لـ VQE مشابهة جداً لـ QAOA
نبدأ بحالة مألوفة هنا حالة الفراغ ثم نتركها تتطور عبر الزمن بسلسلة من الهاملتونيات
المُقسمة إلى أجزاء يمكن التعامل معها حيث n هو عدد الأقسام. الفرق الكبير الوحيد هنا
هو أننا ننشئ حزمة موجة الهادرون في وسط الـ circuit قبل أن نبدأ بتركها تتطور. فكيف يتم
هذا؟ حالة الفراغ هي الحالة الأرضية وقد غطينا بالفعل كيفية تعيين هذا. أما تحضير حزمة موجة
الهادرون فمختلف قليلاً. على هذا الفراغ يمكن إثارة هادرون بإنشاء زوج فرميون-مضاد فرميون على
مواقع متجاورة. بتحضير تراكب لهذه الهادرونات في مواقع مختلفة يمكن تحضير حزمة موجة
عشوائية. المؤلفون وضعوا حزمة الموجة في وسط الـ circuit لمراقبة التطور
دون تجاوز الحدود. لكن تذكروا أن القاعدة الأساسية عند العمل مع وحدات معالجة كمومية مشوشة هي إبقاء
عمق الـ circuit قابلاً للإدارة. لتحقيق ذلك يستخدم بروتوكول SC adapt VQE التناظر
والتسلسلات الهرمية في مقاييس الطول لتحديد دوائر كمومية منخفضة العمق لتحضير الحالة. الفكرة هي أن هذا
سينشئ أنساتز بعدد أقل من المعاملات ما يعادل عمقاً أقل. مزيد من التفاصيل يمكن
بالطبع إيجادها في الورقة أكثر مما لدينا وقت لتغطيته هنا لذا تأكدوا من الاطلاع عليها. الآن لنلقِ نظرة على النتائج. أُجريت هذه التجربة على
جهاز IBM Quantum Heron وطُبقت عدة أنواع مختلفة من تخفيف وقمع الأخطاء
بما في ذلك تقنية أحدث تُسمى إعادة تطبيع فك ترابط المشغل وكذلك الفصل الديناميكي واستقراء الضوضاء الصفرية
ولف Pauli. الآن لنحاول تفسير البيانات. المرصود الذي سنقيسه فعلياً
لمراقبة كيفية انتشار حزمة الموجة هو شيء يُسمى المكثف الكايرالي وهو مجرد
بعض الشيء لكنه في الأساس مرحلة مائع فائق للهادرونات. الآن يمكننا رؤية حزمة الموجة متمركزة هنا على
المواقع المخصصة لتشغيل هذه التجربة حيث يمثل اللون المكثف الكايرالي.
الجانب الأيسر يُظهر النتائج الخالية من الأخطاء من المحاكي بينما الجانب الأيمن يُظهر النتائج من حاسوب
IBM الكمومي Torino. مثالياً يجب أن تكون هذه صوراً معكوسة لبعضها بسبب التناظر لذا يمكنكم رؤية أن هناك
بعض العيوب. هذا المحور العمودي y يمثل أجزاء الزمن التي
قستها سابقاً. فلماذا لا نأخذ بعض المقاطع الأفقية عبر الخطوة الزمنية الأولى والأخيرة للبيانات لنرى
ما يحدث لحزمة الموجة. عند الزمن t يساوي 1 هنا بالبرتقالي المقابل
لهذا المقطع يمكنكم رؤية أن المكثف الكايرالي ضيق ومتموضع. وهو يتوافق جيداً جداً مع
المحاكاة التي أُجريت للمقارنة. عند t يساوي 14 فإنه أكثر انتشاراً بكثير وأقل
تموضعاً. ربما المقارنة مع المحاكي ليست مثالية تماماً الآن لكن لا يزال بإمكانكم رؤية توافق جيد جداً بين النظرية والبيانات
وهو أمر مشجع. في الختام هذا مثال رائع جداً لنوع أعمال المحاكاة التي قد لا تفكرون مبدئياً في
تطبيق الحواسيب الكمومية عليها. لكن في الواقع يمكنكم ذلك وتنجح. ليست مثالية لكن لا يجب أن تكونوا خبراء
في فيزياء الجسيمات لتروا أن دقة الحاسوب الكمومي تتنبأ بالانتشار الخارجي لحزمة الموجة
وهو بالضبط ما نتوقع إيجاده. نأمل أن يستمر العمل المستقبلي في هذا المجال وأن يستمر فيزيائيو الطاقات العالية
في إيجاد طرق لدمج الحوسبة الكمومية في مسارات عملهم. الهدف هو حل المشاكل النظرية بدقة أكبر
وتلك التي لا يمكن حلها كلاسيكياً واستخدام التجارب لقبول أو رفض النظريات أملاً في اكتشاف
فيزياء جديدة وبناء كاشفات محسنة والوصول إلى فهم أفضل للطبيعة على أكثر مستوياتها
أساسية. مثالنا التالي يركز على التحسين وسيكون تعمقاً في ورقة بعنوان حقل الانحياز
للتحسين الكمومي الرقمي المضاد للكظوم والتي أنجزها أعضاء فريق Kipu Quantum في
جامعة بلاد الباسك في إسبانيا. سنبدأ كما فعلنا سابقاً
بسلسلة من التعريفات. الأول هو المضاد للكظوم وهو نوع من التطور يقمع التأثيرات غير الكظومية
التي يختبرها نظام بغض النظر عن مدى سرعة حدوث تلك العمليات. تذكروا النظرية الكظومية من
الحلقة الماضية: عادةً تحتاجون لترك النظام يتطور ببطء شديد إذا أردتم أن يبقى في الحالة الأرضية
وهذه مشكلة كبيرة لأنه كلما كان علينا ترك الأشياء تتطور أبطأ كلما كان لدينا وقت أكثر للأخطاء
لتحدث. القيادة المضادة للكظوم والمختصرة غالباً بـ CD تهدف لمحاربة هذا عن طريق
إضافة حدود تُبطل هذه الإثارات غير المرغوبة. الفكرة الرئيسية هنا هي تسريع التجربة بأكملها
وتقليل عمق الـ circuit الكمومية عن طريق قمع الإثارات التي قد تؤدي إلى انتقالات
زائفة. الآن لنتحدث عن ماهية حقل الانحياز. الخوارزميات التكرارية الأخرى مثل VQE تأخذ معاملات كلاسيكية في
هذه الحالات وتستخدم محسنات كلاسيكية للبحث في فضاء المعاملات متعدد الأبعاد عن تلك المجموعة
التي تعطي أدنى قيمة متوقعة لهاملتوني ثابت. في هذه الحالة يغيرون الهاملتوني بدلاً من ذلك في كل
مرة منتقلين كظومياً من حالة معروفة إلى الحالة المطلوبة. لكن بما أنه لا توجد معاملات كلاسيكية يتم
تمريرها ولا دالة موجية تباينية كيف تُحدّث حالتك من تمرير واحد للهاملتوني إلى التالي؟ حسناً
يضيفون حقل انحياز إلى الهاملتوني. مهما كانت حالة الطاقة الأدنى من التشغيل السابق يضيفون حداً في
الهاملتوني لانحياز الحالة لصالح ذلك. فلماذا هذه التجربة مثيرة
للاهتمام؟ أولاً هذا نهج جديد يمكن تطبيقه بشكل أعم على مشاكل تحسين أخرى
لكن في هذه الحالة طبقوه على مشكلة زجاج اللف Ising. كما ناقشنا سابقاً العديد من مشاكل
التحسين التوافقي يمكن إعادة صياغتها كحل لحالات الطاقة المنخفضة لهاملتونيات Ising. نموذج
Ising هو سلسلة من اللفات المجهرية الموزعة على مصفوفة. يمكن استخدام النموذج لوصف زجاج لف حيث
المغنطة مضطربة أي أن العزوم المغناطيسية الصغيرة موجهة عشوائياً في المصفوفة
ولماذا اعتقدنا أن هذا سينجح؟ لقد غطينا بالفعل كيف نكافح مشكلتين نموذجيتين في
الخوارزميات التباينية عندما غطينا تعريفات الورقة. لكن لتلخيص الخوارزمية التي
يقترحونها تُسرّع التطور لتقليل عمق الـ circuit مع قمع الانتقالات غير الكظومية أيضاً
علاوة على ذلك لا تعتمد على أي روتين تحسين كلاسيكي الذي قد يكون مشكلة تؤدي إلى هضاب
قاحلة والتعثر في حدود دنيا محلية. وأخيراً المؤلفون حرصوا أيضاً على محاذاة التفاعلات في الهاملتوني
المسألة مع اتصالية العتاد في وحدة المعالجة الكمومية الحقيقية وهو أمر مهم دائماً. وأخيراً كيف يعمل هذا؟
كما قلت لا تُستخدم محسنات كلاسيكية هنا كما هو الحال غالباً في الخوارزميات الكمومية التكرارية
بدلاً من ذلك بتغذية الحل من كل تكرار كمدخل للتالي تقوم خوارزمية التحسين الكمومي الرقمي بحقل الانحياز
بتحسين الحالة الأرضية تدريجياً مقربةً إياها أكثر فأكثر إلى
الحالة المتطورة النهائية. ومع بروتوكولات مضادة للكظوم يمكننا فعل ذلك حتى مع دوائر كمومية قصيرة العمق
يجب أن تعمل بسلاسة على عتاد مشوش. لذا عند إجراء التجربة اختار المؤلفون تشغيل
الخوارزمية على حاسوب IBM الكمومي ذي 127 qubit المسمى Brisbane. هنا أظهر المؤلفون
تحسين خوارزمية التحسين لحالة زجاج لف مولدة عشوائياً بجوار أقرب جار
على أكثر من 100 qubit. يقارنون نتائج المحاكاة المثالية من DCQ و BF-DCQ
وكذلك النتيجة التجريبية ويعرضون أيضاً نتيجة من محلل كلاسيكي يُسمى Gurobi كمرجع
بعشر تكرارات فقط يوفر BF-DCQ تحسناً جذرياً مقارنة بـ
DCQ. رغم أن النتيجة التجريبية مختلفة قليلاً عن النتيجة المثالية بسبب الضوضاء إلا أن الأداء لا يزال
أفضل من DCQ المثالي. هذا يُظهر أنه لا يزال هناك تقدم ممتاز كثير يتحقق في
مجال التحسين الكمومي ونتائج جيدة يتم الإبلاغ عنها على أكثر من 100 qubit لأول
مرة تقريباً. وأخيراً وليس آخراً ورقة مثيرة للاهتمام جداً تستكشف التنبؤ ببنية mRNA من أصدقائنا في
Maddna Pharmaceuticals وعنوانها التنبؤ بالبنية الثانوية لـ mRNA باستخدام حواسيب كمومية بمقياس
الفائدة العملية. للبداية إذا كنتم مثلي لم تأخذوا دورة أحياء منذ سنوات يمكنكم تجديد معلوماتكم عن
ماهية mRNA. الحمض النووي الريبوزي المرسال هو نوع من RNA يشارك في تخليق البروتينات وهو
يقرأ التعليمات المعطاة من DNA. البنية الثانوية لـ mRNA هي تقريباً كيفية طي السلسلة
ومشكلة التنبؤ بالبنية الثانوية لـ RNA هي مشكلة إيجاد الطي الأكثر استقراراً لتسلسل
قواعد النيوكليوتيدات التي تشكل DNA و RNA وهي C و G و U و A. هذه
الصورة هنا تُظهر بعض بنى الطي الشائعة الموجودة في mRNA. كل تمييز لوني هنا يُظهر
بنية ثانوية مختلفة لكن الخصائص الدقيقة لما يجعل إحدى هذه البنى أفضل من
أخرى ليست مفهومة جيداً. كل ما يمكننا فعله هو معرفة أيها لديه أقل طاقة حرة مقارنة بالحالة
غير المطوية وهنا تتدخل الحواسيب الكمومية. فلماذا البنى الثانوية لـ mRNA
مهمة؟ التنبؤ الدقيق بها حاسم فعلاً ليس فقط لفهم DNA وجيناتنا بل أيضاً
لتصميم علاجات قائمة على RNA مثل لقاح كوفيد-19. هناك سبب للاعتقاد بأن النهج في
هذه الورقة سينجح لأن هذا معروف منذ زمن طويل كمشكلة تحسين هائلة للحواسيب
الكلاسيكية بسبب العدد الهائل من التكوينات الممكنة ولبعض التكوينات هي فعلاً معروفة كمشكلة
NP-complete. لكن على حاسوب كمومي يمكننا صياغة التنبؤ بالبنية الثانوية كمشكلة
تحسين ثنائية وهو شيء نعرف كيف نتعامل معه. علاوة على ذلك هناك أدلة في الأدبيات العلمية بالفعل
على تنبؤ دقيق بـ RNA على أجهزة كمومية صغيرة الحجم ومحاكيات كمومية. لذا السؤال الواضح هو
هل سينجح هذا على عتاد أكبر؟ التجربة أُجريت باستخدام شيء يُسمى القيمة الشرطية
عند المخاطرة لمحلل القيم الذاتية الكمومي التباينيي وهو تعديل على خوارزمية VQE التقليدية ومن المتوقع
أن يحقق تقارباً أفضل. هذا الرسم البياني يُظهر توزيع احتمالات القياس
لسلاسل البت المأخوذة كعينات مع الطاقات المقابلة لحالة 42
نيوكليوتيد و80 qubit. هنا سلاسل البت ترمز إلى إقران
النيوكليوتيدات. يوضح أن سلسلة البت ذات الطاقة الأدنى لها قيمة طاقة -140 وهي تطابق أدنى
طاقة وجدها المحلل الكلاسيكي المقارن وهذا رائع. وهذه هي البنية المطوية المثلى
لسلسلة النيوكليوتيدات تلك بناءً على سلسلة البت ذات الطاقة الأدنى التي وجدها
العتاد. وبهذا وصلنا إلى نهاية هذه الحلقة. هدفي هنا لم يكن إثقالكم
بتفاصيل من أوراق بحثية مختلفة. كما قلت أردت ببساطة أن أعطيكم سياقاً كافياً لفهم كيف يبدو
العمل المتطور في المجال الآن. الأمل هو أن هذا سيُحرك بعض التروس في
رؤوس الجميع وأنه برؤية كيف يقارب الآخرون المشاكل ستتمكنون من إجراء ربط وتكون لديكم الثقة
لتجربة تجارب كمومية جديدة ربما لم تكونوا لتجربوها من قبل. وربما بعضها لن
ينجح وهذا لا بأس به فهذا هو البحث العلمي. للمضي قدماً تذكروا أن أنواع المشاكل التي نهتم
بها يمكن تجميعها إما حسب المنهجية أو حسب الموضوع وقد وضعنا تلك التي نعتقد أنها
الأكثر وعداً على المدى القصير. تذكروا أن الحوسبة الكمومية ليست جيدة لكل شيء وهذا في الحقيقة شهادة
على مدى براعتنا في الحوسبة الكلاسيكية. مجرد أنكم تعتقدون أنه يمكنكم تطبيق الحوسبة الكمومية
على مشكلة لا يعني أنها ستعطي نتائج مثيرة للاهتمام. للأسف عليكم مراعاة التوسع وعمق
الـ circuit سلاح ذو حدين. نحتاجه أن يكون كبيراً بشكل ملحوظ للقيام بعمل مثير لا تستطيع الحواسيب
الكلاسيكية القيام به لكن حالياً بسبب ضوضاء العتاد لا يمكننا دفعه إلى أحجام ضخمة لأن الدقة
ستتراجع. الأمر كله يتعلق بإيجاد تلك النقطة المثالية ومعرفة أنها هدف متحرك. لذا خذوا بعض الوقت
بين الآن والحلقة القادمة للتفكير حقاً في بعض المشاكل التي صادفتموها وكيف قد تريدون مقاربتها بما تعلمناه
حتى هذه النقطة. كونوا مبدعين ولا تقيدوا أنفسكم وإذا كانت لديكم أي أفكار حتى لو اعتقدتم أنها
مجنونة بعض الشيء أخبروني في التعليقات أدناه. شكراً على المشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة